hello everyone branal and i we were
working on a project and the name of our
project is identification of pathway
leading to autotoxicity by the use of
suspecting
so before diving straight into the topic
i would like to tell you briefly about
cisplatin and autotoxicity
cisplatin it is a well-known
chemotherapeutic drug that has been used
for the treatment of numerous human
cancers including bladder head and neck
lung ovarian and testicular cancers
sysplatin exerts anti-cancer activity
via multiple mechanisms but its most
acceptable mechanism involves the
generation of dna lesions by interacting
with purine bases on dna followed by
activation of several signal
transduction pathways which finally
leads to apoptosis
sysplatine induces
hearing loss that is its side effect and
it is usually bilateral and irreversible
and is particularly serious in pediatric
population
with sense with cancers like
neuroblastomas cns head and neck cancers
while irradiation of the base of the
skull of brain is also performed
now i would like to tell you about
auto toxicity what is auto toxicity it
is basically when a person develops
hearing or balance problems due to a
medicines so here our medicine is
splitting and it can happen when a when
someone is on high dose of a drug that
treats cancers infections or other
illness
so this so the specific aim of our
project is to identify the genes and
pathways related to the side effects of
cisplatin using the gene expression data
from split in treated lung cancer sets
now for that we took a data set for
which the geo essential number was gst
14814 and its title was
prognostic and predictive gene signature
for adjuvant chemotherapy in recent
resected non-small cell lung cancers for
this we took 133 samples out of which
adc was 71 as qcc were 52 lcuc were 10.
adc stands for adreno carcinoma sqcc
cells stands for squamous carcinoma
cells lcuc stands for large cell
undifferentiated carcinoma
so now i would like to hand over it to
manal and he will tell you further about
the project
thank you uh so further from the from
the data set we did
we did the principal component analysis
or the pca on two conditions like one of
us the one with all of our samples
including adc else using sqcc and other
one was with the adc and sqcc already
and while doing the analysis we found
out that the data distribution of the
adc and sqcc was made much better than
over the original data so we focused our
analysis on adc and sqcc samples
after after finalizing the group of adc
and sqcc we did its differential
expression analysis on ms excel where we
calculated the p value using the t test
and from the t test we calculated the
false discovery rate or fdr which was
then sorted on the basis of zero point
less than zero point zero five and after
that we calculated the log full change
value which was filtered on the basis of
greater than one and less than minus one
when all these parameters were met we
found out that out of thirteen thousand
five hundred fourteen genes we got only
7386 genes
for the functional annotation the our
7386 probes
were then used were significantly
differentially expressed between adc and
sqcc samples which were then
functionally annotated using the using
david annotation tool and endless
pathway were identified by the human
gage pipeline from on the teas to
bioinfo servo
as we can see these are the results from
our human cage pipeline and most of the
enriched pathways are tumor-related
pathways with significant upregulated
upregulation contributing genes
the whole enrichment shows that even for
pathways involved in tumor tuberogenesis
different tissue types will always
always have
will have different expression patterns
and significantly our glutathione
pathway is a common defense mechanism
against the cisplatin-induced
upregulation of the ross or knox 3g
which are
highly implicated in the auto toxicity
and for the david functional annotation
result after the our human cage pipeline
the 7386 genes
were then uploaded on the david
annotation from where we found out
uh 215 pathways and out of those 215
pathways
we'd selected top 20 out of which we
found out that only 13 caused auto
toxicity and whereas the remaining 7
does not cause the auto toxicity
from all these we found it we had the
conclusions like
several genes were identified with
which which were differentially
expressed between adc and sqc lung
cancers with their morphological defense
differences most of the genes and
associated pathways are related to the
cell differentiation humorogenesis
and dna replication
among the enriched pathways we also
discovered that glutathione in a
metabolism pathway that is embraced this
path is implicated in a form of a
defense against the cisplatin-induced or
toxicity in cells from
the human inner ear
we also showed that it is possible to
identify specific gene expression
patterns and pathways related to side
effects of splutten treated treatment in
the lung cancer
thank you
thank you everyone